UKRAINE.
NO ONE HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH ANY
CRIMES HERE.
IT IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF LAX
SECURITY AT MAR-A-LAGO.
"OUTFRONT," MICHAEL SALA.
ONE OF THE REPORTERS BEHIND THIS
STORY.
THANK YOU FOR COMING IN.
YOU, QUOTE ONE MAR-A-LAGO MEMBER
WHO IS A FORMER INVESTMENT
BANKER SAYING THIS.
IT WAS THE NEAR IMPORTANT RUSE
AND SHE PLAYED THE PART.
HOW WAS SHE ABLE TO GAIN SUCH
ACCESS IN MAR-A-LAGO?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, YOU THINK
ABOUT ALL THE PROPS, THE
JEWELRY, THE BRAND NEW MERCEDES,
G-WAGON, THE POWER GRACELETS.
SHE REPLIED HEART AND SHE WAS
VERY GOOD.
FOR ALL INTENTS AND PURPOSES,
SHE HAD THE GUESTS CONVINCED SHE
WAS A MEMBER OF THE ROTHCHILD
FAMILY.
>> THIS INVESTIGATION INTO THIS
WOMAN COMES THREE YEARS AFTER
SEPARATE INCIDENTS OF CHINESE
NATIONALS ENTERING THE GROUNDS,
AS YOU REMEMBER.
WHAT HAVE YOU LEARNED ABOUT THE
SECURITY PROCESS FOR PEOPLE TO
GET INTO MAR-A-LAGO SINCE DONALD
TRUMP HAS LEFT OFFICE?
>> IT'S AN INTERESTING QUESTION.
WHAT YOU'RE DEALING WITH
MAR-A-LAGO, YOU HAVE A PRIVATE
CLUB AND THE PRESIDENT'S
RESIDENCE.
THERE WAS A SAYING THERE, WE HAD
NEVER HAD ANY FORMER PRESIDENT
LIVING IN A HOTEL.
TELL CHALLENGES OF PROVIDING
SECURITY ARE REALLY DIFFICULT.
FOR INSTANCE, YOU CAN HAVE
GUESTS COMING IN AND OUT OF ONE
PART OF THE COMPOUND AND THERE
IS THE PRESIDENT WITH HIS FAMILY
AT THE OTHER.
SO THE WHOLE PROBLEM IS BEING
ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT SECURITY
THAT PROTECTS FAMILY IS THAT ALL
THE RECORDS THAT WERE THERE AT
THE TIME.
IT IS A DIFFICULT THK TO ASK.
A JUGGLING ACT.
>> SHE SAID SHE HASN'T BROKEN
ANY LAWS.
TELLING THE POST GAZETTE THAT
THIS WHOLE SITUATION IS SOME
MISUNDERSTANDING.
AT WHAT POINT DID TRUMP SECURITY
REALIZE WHAT WAS GOING ON?
>> ACTUALLY, THEY NEVER FOUND
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON.
I THINK WE PRETTY MUCH TOLD
THEM.
IT WAS ABOUT A YEAR, KIND OF A
SECRET.
AT LEAST AMONG MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE THERE.
IT WAS IN MARCH.
THEY BROKE IT TO THE STAFF AND
THE OTHER PEOPLE.
HEY, BE CAREFUL.
THIS ISN'T THE PERSON YOU THINK
IT IS.
AND YOU SHOULD PROBABLY NOT
ALLOW HER HERE.
DON'T GET INVOLVED WITH HER IN
ANY WAY.
THAT WAS IN MARCH.
SO IT WAS CLOSE TO A YEAR LATER.
>> THERE IS A PIECE THAT SUMS IT
ALL UP.
TELL QUESTION IS, WAS IT A FRAUD
OR AN INTELLIGENCE THREAT?
HAVE YOU LANDED ANYWHERE CLOSE
TO A CONCLUSION.
>> NO.
THAT'S THE IDEA.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHO WAS THERE.
AT ANY GIVEN TIME, SOMEBODY
COULD GET INTO THIS FACILITY
UNDER A FAKE NAME.
A FAKE IDENTITY.
SHE WAS IN AND OUT OF THERE FIVE
TIMES.
NOBODY CHECKED HER I.D.
SHE COULD HAVE BEEN GOING INTO
NEIMAN MARCUS FOR ALL THAT
MATTERED.
AND WILL THE PRESIDENT WAS THE